hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in to another episode I've left
to be taught Monday September 25th
long live John Bonham today was the day
that John Bonham passed the greatest
drummer of all time there's no argument
there is no argument there is no I can't
even believe it sometimes when somebody
tries to go like what about no well what
no no right I don't care what anybody
says there is no one cooler no better
groove no better vibe flavor everything
no no one more outlaw and dangerous no
more more legendary when you think of
best drummer everyone's gonna say John
Bonham unless they're one of those dicks
that's trying to just start a little I'm
like you know I'll show these guys I'll
just say someone else just to get a rise
out of them that's the only time anybody
does that John Bonham the best ever
there will be never another one like him
go on today
throw on some Zeppelin and and just just
[ __ ] enjoy the glory of that man's
groove I'm talking you know I've had all
the drummers on on here a lot of
drummers I'm about to have Kenny Aronoff
on here pretty soon incredible drummer
josh freese incredible drummer all these
drums Jimbo just a few weeks ago on here
all of them say John Bonham you know
what I mean I mean [ __ ] he made me want
to play drums and I couldn't play on
that's terrible that's like I grew the
hair out I got this down down down a dad
and yeah no I don't got this I'm gonna
sing john bonham love you man
long live that man ah great guest today
thanks for tuning in it is a little late
today here it is in the afternoon and a
good reason rightfully so last night I
was doing the Comedy Store in the main
room and and you know just another night
at the store going down there working
working on some new stuff and joy and
myself and went on stage in the main
room my my friends show
Agostino ZOA had a show asked me to do
it went on stage when I got out there
all I do dr. Dre's in the crowd you you
crushed it that was cool man I was like
oh [ __ ] Dre you know dr. Dre at the
stores is rad and after the show and met
him in the parking lot
took a photo he you know we exchanged a
couple of words and he said he he he
Doug what I was doing I made him laugh
he asked around what my name was Elvis I
just it wasn't it was insane man that
came home I couldn't sleep I was just
jacked like wow dr. Dre was at the show
you know like does these people you know
that that you know inspire you growing
up and NWA was definitely all way up
there on the top of the list as far as
like wow these guys are the [ __ ] goods
they shook open their earth they were
outlaws I've talked about it many times
I did a movie with Ice Cube that was
absolutely monumental to me and I'll
never forget it and that NWA film last
year was incredible their music the
chronic are you kidding me the
documentary on HBO the Defiant ones
everything about Dre the Beats
headphones everything about this guy man
and just to talk to him for a couple
minutes last night it was just like
Wow and now we sit there and think eight
years ago I wasn't even [ __ ] doing
stand-up and Here I am 51 years old in
that Comedy Store and dr. Dre is in the
audience it's just [ __ ] crazy so go
for it man get out there people and go
for it who knows what's gonna happen we
got [ __ ] we got [ __ ] shaken up out
there man so you got to be living your
life you do not know what's gonna happen
we got a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
shaken up out there great guest today
talk about inspiring this [ __ ] man is
basically the Forrest Gump of Rock Dave
catching - my guest today and if you
love Eagles of Death Metal or Queens of
the Stone Age or earthlings or masters
of reality or Mark Lanegan and many many
many other of those great desert
classics caius you are gonna love my man
and you do love my man if you love that
music and you know who he is and if you
don't know who he is you will today and
you will fall in love with him he
stopped by or I stopped by yesterday to
the Eagles of Death metals rehearsal as
they were getting ready to go on tour
today with Mastodon and Russian Circles
to finish part two of that tour that I
saw about three months ago at the
Palladium in Hollywood and I'm gonna go
see it again in San Diego next month
anyway we sat down we talked all kinds
of great stuff this guy has stories for
days man for [ __ ] days he's also got
a brand new radio show we talked about
that we talked about him growing up in
Memphis we get a lot of a lot of
conversation going about the 80s in
Hollywood which is absolutely cool and
it was an honor to have month
show we also of course talked about Bo
C's go fund page which I want you guys
to go to go fun.com and hit up Brian
O'Connor and donate to that page it's
for a great cause it was so exciting to
have this guy on I just wow man I want
to give a shout out to some incredible
donations this week to let the B talk if
you want to donate it's patreon.com
slash dean del rey
we got Eric apex hero Fleming thank you
buddy
really cool eatin box eatin box that
says that sounds like I got this you
play in the scorpions and the guitar
eatin box weighed stool weight stool
[ __ ] hey man thank you guys for the
donations keeping the machine up and
running and alive see you in Chicago
this week can't wait Chicago I will be
there Thursday Friday Saturday at Zanies
in Rosemont this week 28 29 30 and on
the 30 shows two shows at night it'll be
Josh wolf and myself together and on the
late Saturday show we're gonna be doing
a little Q&A after which will be fun
come down and hang looking forward to
that and then I'm off to New York City
for October 1st through the 10th be at
the stand every night except for the 6
when I'll be seeing Bruce Springsteen on
Broadway cannot wait for that and don't
forget November 2nd it is bill burr
myself in Iowa at the Surf ballroom a
lot of great stuff going on a lot of
great guests coming up I love all you
guys keep spreading the word and please
I can't I can't stress enough what it
means to this show up for you to to
subscribe it'll be fantastic it helps it
it puts it in the top 100 200 whatever
we want to keep it in there
we want the industry to notice I don't
give a [ __ ] I do this thing in my
[ __ ] bedroom and I'll do it no matter
what I love it oh speaking of love it
you guys have been asking me out uh how
I've been losing weight and getting in
shape and I'll tell you man I've been
eating way better so long I would just
eat junk eat out late night just
whatever
burgers fries garbage just throwing
garbage down my throat thinking I'm good
I'm bulletproof I worked out last month
I went hiking I can eat anything nah nah
man I eat clean now and the way I do it
is I use hellofresh
these guys are fantastic total farm to
box company you ask what a farm to box
company and so they basically ship fresh
ingredients right to your doorstep
super easy to cook super easy and get
the classic box the veggie box or the
family box and you can get three four
five different meals per week delivered
right to your house for either two or
four people it's so great man it and
it's all fresh ingredients and tastes
fantastic
and I said it before maybe you swiped
left and you got a great date coming
over or swiped right I don't know which
one it is I've never used it it's a
swipe left or swipe right but maybe you
got a great day coming over and you want
to look like chef Dean dope Oh Dean Dell
what does that ship chef boyardee chef
boyardee n-- maybe you want to look like
a a [ __ ] a culinary king
well hello fresh we'll help you do that
you can sit in there cook up some fresh
ingredients measured exact quantities so
there's no food waste you know I'm
saying they got two full-time registered
dietitians on staff to ensure the
nutrition is just balanced and perfect
for you nice and clean like a
delivers food right to your doorstep in
a recyclable insulated box for free and
it's less than ten dollars a meal
everybody's like oh man I can't afford
that I go to Burger King this is the
same price of not cheaper than Burger
King because you know you go to Burger
King you get that deal meal but then
y'all saying you got an extra nuggets
and and in a shake and an onion rings
about eight thousand calories and you're
not like $12 this is cheaper and right
now if you use the code then I talked to
him about to get you guys hooked up you
can save $30 off your first week of
hellofresh with talk 30 use the code
Dell razors talk 30 check them out on
YouTube they've got some great clips on
there you can look at the meals go to
the website and check it out you want to
get this immediately and start eating
clean and get nice and trim you know
what I mean for the end of the world you
want to look good for the end of the
world don't you I want to look good for
the end of the world hellofresh less
than $10 a meal talk 30 is the code I
just slipped into Brody's voice you got
it get your hello fresh also my great
great sponsor Elko and Harley over a
year and a half now these guys have been
sponsoring the podcast you want to get
yourself a motorcycle two-wheel fever
it's that time in your life and speaking
of that you know my guest lives out in
Joshua Tree Dave does and man riding out
to Joshua Tree you want to talk about
something spiritual go to El Cajon
Harley tell them I need a Harley I need
to ride to Joshua Tree and then from
there just keep going to the Grand
Canyon out to Zion spin into you know
highway 70 over Vail Pass and then drop
into Sturgis give a salute to Mount
Rushmore on your new Harley from El
Cajon Harley hit him up Elko and Harley
comm ask for my boy Gregg
they get a brand-new 2018 they got all
kinds of good stuff going our Lee's got
great new machines I love the C vo line
this year I love the C vo line this year
hint-hint El Cajon I need one hit him up
then get financed go to their website
fill out a quick form or trade in your
motorcycle or get it serviced el cajon
Harley I love all you guys I cannot
stress enough how much I enjoy your
emails dean del rey at yahoo.com thank
you so much for your suggestions your
donations and your love keep the candles
lit let's get into it right now Dave
catching bedrock bedrock la it's weird
I've never I've never been to this place
and I've played music all my life this
is the second place I've gone with the
Eagles of Death Metal where I've never
been this is insane that other one was
that wacky cool studio where I interval
and I see that place is [ __ ] great
it's one of the coolest I've been in
introduce yourself my man I am David
catching nice to meet you on the radio
there everybody it's so great to sit
down with you man it's uh it's I I'm
trying to interview everyone from the
desert you know from the scene yeah I
mean well it's time for me it is time
for you and you are one of the ground
zeroes of the desert scene you know I'm
saying I'm a grandad for sure
grandad you know 56 56 I'm 51 you are
not I am how do you do that
isn't it amazing to be 56 years old and
out there tearing it up on and playing
rock and roll yeah I thought I'd be dead
by 26 I know what did you think you'd be
dead from drugs no I just figured like a
you know being on the road car accident
plane crash yeah you know Buddy Holly
style yeah Buddy Holly Holly died on my
birthday he did yeah you know it's rare
Bill burn I
to the Surf ballroom on in November
November second and that's the last gig
Buddy Holly Big Bopper ritchie valens
played that's a really shitty birthday
present yeah thank God it was on the
same year that have been a total bummer
yeah that's the day the music died bye
bye miss American Pie man Big Bopper I
mean come on Big Bopper Richie Valens
man that was a crusher how old was he he
was only like 20 right I guess so man
young at that time when I think about
that that era of music I really think
about what's almost going on now as far
as back then it would take like three or
four guys or even all the Motown acts
that had maybe one or two singles and
they'd put them on a tour together to
fill rooms that's kind of like what
these festivals are now you know yeah
you got a point I never thought about it
like that but yeah that's exactly what
it's like yeah get tons of people
together to enjoy and celebrate yeah and
get people butts in the seats you know
what I mean
yeah now you're from Memphis right I am
from Memphis Tennessee
I just went to Memphis my first time
went to Graceland and that was pretty
interesting Memphis you know I've never
been to Graceland we didn't we used to
drive by we were kids because Elvis had
such a crazy Christmas decoration thing
going on yeah you are alive when Elvis
was living there oh yeah he died when I
was 16 77 and were you still in Memphis
I was still in Memphis but I actually
was on vacation in Florida when he died
oh wow that had to be you what's
interesting to me about Memphis is and
I've never been there and I was finally
there it they have not touched that city
as far I thought like I was in the 40s
yeah it's pretty I was just there not
too long ago we played there and it
hasn't changed the whole bill Street
they kind of [ __ ] up and made right
they make it like New Orleans but yeah
not quite right right and when I was a
kid bill Street was really cool still
you know like it didn't have like they
weren't trying too hard it was still had
the vibe
and still had some of the venues but now
they've made it kind of a music row kind
of thing right growing up in Memphis
what was that like I've never met
anybody grew up in the Memphis you know
is it rock and roll was it yeah I'm
originally from Arkansas and I moved to
Memphis in 1960 sixty-eight right and so
I was seven and it was really cool up
until the mid 80s that's when I moved
out here 84 I started coming here in Los
Angeles around 82 and up into that point
the music scene was amazing every you
know every punk band stopped through
Memphis because that was like kind of
when you know seventy seventy seven
through 82 right everybody started
coming through the Sex Pistols played oh
yeah they did play there yeah my friend
invited me to go and I couldn't get out
because I was 16 and my mom wouldn't let
me go because it was a school night not
because it was Sex Pistols she's right
about that but it was a school night and
my friend went and he didn't get in
because they over sold that that place
by like 800 tickets so there's a big
riot there that night Wow but every
everybody used to play at this we we
started playing at a place called the
well and that turned into the antenna
and in the early 80s you know that's how
we how I ended up coming out as a Black
Flag played and my band opened up for
Lamb and Circle Jerks and gun club gun
club wow that's actually how I came to
LA Jeffrey Lee invited us to open for
gun club in LA so we drove all the way
for a gig and what was the name of that
band the modifiers and you drove all the
way from Memphis to LA to open for gun
club yeah
that isn't me you know I find all bands
not all bands but a lot of them
backwards I remember I was way into this
band 16 horsepower oh yeah they're great
hahaha great man that that song saw I
think of it that the EP was great and I
was loving this band for a couple years
and then my buddy goes oh man I mean you
know if you love these guys you got to
get into the gun club that's what that's
what their sound is I was like really
and then BOOM
I am you know yeah the first gun club
album is perfect and then every other
one is amazing
I mean Miami's awesome yeah I really and
I talk about it a lot I skipped over
punk rock and then this is what I love
about music sonic highways comes out and
I really get into that DC episode and
all that you know Bad Brains and Fugazi
and all that stuff as a kid I was only
into a few I love Dead Kennedys I cuz I
San Francisco in our band where they
have solos yeah and I was way into
holiday in Cambodia to me it was uh to
me and still to this day it's about a
song a song hits me I go goddamn that's
a great [ __ ] song now as you you know
get older and stuff you you love
attitude or not even older but you know
you'll have attitude or you love
something but it's still at the end of
the day it's a song like you know
holiday in Cambodia and then I worship
Devo from ground up oh yeah when they I
remember watching them on SNL SNL yeah I
was working at peaches records and tapes
at the time and they actually put up
this big giant TV screen to play the
satisfaction video that part of their
role models amazed mourner brothers
luckily they were on a big label right
and I remember watching that on SNL back
when they had every cool band
maybe that every week I mean but also we
had Don Kirshner's rock concert
unbelievable in concert and a Midnight
Special
yeah and you know 90% of it was not
stuff you really cared about but there'd
always be like kiss who are Aerosmith or
Devo or whoever and they play live live
man Black Sabbath I remember seeing
Black Sabbath on there yeah man yeah UFO
I mean it's really crazy to think about
you're 56 and I'm 51 so we grew up in
the greatest music era of all time I
think so I really did too I think
between like there
early 60s and the late 70s some of the
greatest music of all time yep and I'm
hard to even beat nowadays yeah and also
bands in that era got to do more than
one or two records so you really got to
see something for us from let's say
Zeppelin wanted to end through the
outdoor yeah that's a totally different
band nowadays there's great music now
love it and I always tell people there's
so much great music but are they gonna
get to do two three four or five records
are they gonna stay together can they
survive you know what I mean how long
can you just go [ __ ] I'm in the van
now exactly and a lot of those bands did
so many great records you know now it's
it's hard after your first album you put
everything into it it's always kind of
hard to keep going the second album you
know the first album took you ten years
to write you've finally got it out so
it's perfect yeah next album you've got
six months but things don't really work
like they used to you know it's not it's
not like that where bands were like
Alice Cooper bands and stuff they were
putting out two three albums a year yeah
a year yeah they put out an album to
Berlin for yeah put out go out on the
road for four months and then they come
back with another album because they
were writing on the road and super-tight
yeah go in and nail it that come out the
next you know so a lot of people don't
do that because there's no big budgets
to pay for it so people are scrambling
to you know they come home work jobs
yeah exactly [ __ ] work jobs man you
know it's you know I talk to a lot of
bands and I'm like so what do you do in
the guy yeah I got this now the key to
the game is to find that cool [ __ ]
job where the boss lets you leave you
know what I'm saying yeah that seems to
be the necessity of rock and roll to be
able to play for years and years is do
you have that cool job which happens to
be with a lot of people computer stuff I
can do this on the road yeah the
soundcheck they're working yeah yeah
yeah I gotta get on the computer and
work painters record stores pizza joints
yeah
yeah those were those were the only jobs
when I was growing up and same with you
if you had long hair there was only two
jobs
you either carpenter landscaper you know
that kind of [ __ ] or you worked at like
you know on a music place like Guitar
Center or Mesa Boogie or some kind you
know Dunlap you know whatever well not
long hairs could work you know yeah I
always worked at record stores and pizza
joints cuz that way you could get your
music cheap or you could eat -
absolutely yeah yeah that was vital you
know like I think the rule and the band
would be one guy has to work at like a
burrito place oh yeah you know then we
all eat around 4:00 we come in you know
then one guy works in a record store so
we get free like cassettes on the side
the you know Center demos out then
another dude would do construction so he
could make some real money yeah kid kids
don't know about that because they can
download songs free back in when I was a
kid you had to buy Hana records and then
home taping came along but we never
really like ripped off like we only
tapes usually if you take the stuff you
buy yes in your car yeah that was the
trick was to buy the LP and then you
could just record it then you have the
LP and cassette and then when the
cassette came out you could go cassette
to cassette you know the dual cassette
duplicator and that way you had a backup
so in case your your play or ate it but
you didn't like really steal you didn't
steal music at all except from those
dollar does want penny Columbia house
you know you give him a penny and to get
ten albums and you ditch him that was
that was the early stealing of music
robbing people anyway yeah I never went
for that there's always seems super
fishy to me but I knew people that did
that they would do like three or four
times thirty for the whole collection
yeah yeah yeah it's funny to think about
that too because they I didn't even know
at the time but now when you look at
them they didn't have barcodes and [ __ ]
that was a separate pressing for those
labels I was yeah like if you look on
ebay it
like kiss alive to Columbia House
version with no bar code or whatever
weird
you remember those Keitel cover of those
records but they were covers at first
before it was original artists I am I
didn't even know you get one and it'd be
like this isn't kiss exactly man they
would totally rip you off maybe in the
tiniest font ever you would see that not
by original band
I felt [ __ ] robbed on that man yeah
that was pretty pretty uncool for sure
so you're growing up in Memphis and what
gets you into guitar is that what band
and what record do you get well my
brother had a bunch of bands in the 60s
and 70s so he got me in like watching
his band got me into wanting to play and
then he showed me a fused to sneak his
guitar out from under the bed my brother
Jack he had he had a band called Thunder
head writers web spider's web was a good
one
Gasper cool yes for cool yeah he had a
bunch of great bands and they did they
did some originals but mostly like Alice
Cooper Montrose mantra ever you know
Hendrix Beatles whatever and I used to
sneak his Les Paul out from under the
bed and he caught me one day and asked
me if I really wanted to learn you know
he showed and he showed me a deuce by
kiss that was a perfect the first song I
look well I didn't really learn how to
play it very well but yeah and after
that I you know I saved up some money
about one hundred and fifty dollar
Madeira Les Paul jr. copy and borrowed
some money from my mom to get a little
crate amp and now yeah off what your
parents do for a living
my mom sold pallets and my dad was a
golf pro he was a golf pro yeah he well
I mean he ran a golf course right so
Caddyshack yeah exactly man every summer
I was picking up golf balls diving in a
lake getting retrieving the balls and I
was mostly driving range picking up golf
balls for a living it was fun driving
around I got really good at they have a
thing to pick up the ball yeah yeah yeah
I'd be driving in the golf cart just
picking up golf balls and I still suck
at golf I never
really got into it when I was a kid I
was a good putter but I never really
played I loved driving man yeah I was
into that [ __ ] you play now
I don't play now but I used to sneak on
and play I was just horrible but I could
drive the [ __ ] as well I remember I was
so into John Daly back in the day that
does a fat guy and he's fat and I'm
found I could golf oh yeah man smoking
cigarettes out of real athletes yeah
[ __ ] yeah where Mackey sweaters and
pants I was like he's kind of rock and
roll [ __ ] yeah man that guy was cold
Marius what record though what record
gets you popping on it on to start start
playing well yeah well my sister asked
for Ziggy Stardust the year came out for
Christmas and I bought her that and
that's kind of around that time I think
that's what really got me going and then
right after that my brother had Alice
Cooper easy action and a couple of Black
Sabbath like masters reality master of
reality and uh and uh sabotage right and
those were on 8-track a track yeah and I
used to listen to those and that Alice
Cooper album easy action is pretty crazy
and he also had pretties for you the two
weirdest Alice Cooper albums yeah yeah I
was Cooper I missed Alice Cooper because
of course it was for me it was kiss cuz
I'm just you know but I did like
eighteen you know oh hell yeah
what a great tune but later on Alice
Cooper to me is that 80s stuff like boys
and then when I saw Superman the
documentary on manager I was like holy
[ __ ] man I was good I mean I knew he was
great you know like that all kind of
early Alice Cooper Band and that stuff
but I never really dove into it until
that and then I was like god this is a
great garage kind of uh were they from
Detroit or something yeah yeah they were
actually from Phoenix
wait he lives in Phoenix right that's
where they were from oh really
they moved to Detroit and then they
started coming out to LA [ __ ] never knew
that yeah Frank Zappa put out their
first two records
kappa man what a gene is zappa put out
the first two yeah on the pumpkin label
a bizarre-o bizarre back then it was wow
you're a big vinyl guy oh yeah yeah me
too man I didn't take you up to our
house when you're out in the desert I
gotta get out there yeah we hutch and I
kept this one little house where all our
records are and we've got thousands of
records up there oh no you have the
Rancho studio right yeah and you have
other houses there it's like a compound
yeah Brian O'Connor yep next door yeah
and I keep the other house at hutch and
I moved in and bands when they're out
there they stay there and then the third
house is a studio yeah Wow and then
where is your house Theo - I live at the
studio yeah you live at the studio I
remember I saw a thing on Instagram once
you're like you come out here you get
your ass shot like people after that
sonic highways really wanted to go out
there alright it's freaky people you
know there's 20 no trespassing signs
that people just jump up and come up the
road anyway and I have pretty crazy
neighbors that do they have lots of gun
I mean we all have guns out there cause
you need them and my neighbors will [ __ ]
them up
well you don't know what's going on
people could be cooking out there or
growing weed or anything I mean a lot of
the the desert and I wanted to get into
this with you because we were out there
last weekend for the the benefit for
Brian which by the way there's a great
GoFundMe page help him out we're
battling his cancer and we want to get
the fund up but it's go fund me.com
slash Brian O'Connor Brian O'Connor and
please donate to this because it's a you
know it's he's the greatest he is the
great never met him you would know how
great he is
and he deserves he deserves everybody to
pitch in yeah cuz he'll do it for you
yeah man
but my point is being out there here
comes the birthday boy right here Jesse
Hughes
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Jessie happy
birthday to you [ __ ] yes turd it's
Jesse's birthday just got a pair of
sunglasses we're looking at oh my god
they look like butterflies it looks like
a but it actually looks like a TransAm
eagle
it looks like the eagle painted on the
Trans Am yeah Eagles of Trans Am anyway
so let's get back into that the desert I
was out there last weekend and you guys
played and Cree did crush it was a big
benefit but yeah kidding me dude that
was great I think that was I think that
was our best show with Jenny and Jorma
how great is she it's unbelievable how
good she is on bass man when they do the
Sabbath thing oh hello tempo they do a
bunch of different things
[Music]
yeah man fantastic engine all the way
without amazing moves now where's she
from she played with whole their crappy
Courtney Love yes right great great
guitar player - she's in Corel great
guitar oh yeah wow she's so smoking on
stage survived and and her plane is and
then her tone is killer
oh yes now she rips it that score oh
yeah
anyway so we're getting back into that
we're out there on the benefit it's
awesome and it was my first time out to
Joshua Tree can you believe it I've got
really was well I've been to Coachella a
zillion times I've been to Palm Springs
a zillion times and I go to Arizona many
times but I had never gone to Joshua
Tree the actual the place and pioneer
town where you guys did the gig and
everything where we did a gig with you
right yeah yeah yeah I sang a little
ac/dc yeah man we got to rock that out
that was [ __ ] great you know I did
that because I think that it's a lot
like people with Depeche Mode or
something they all say they love them
but most people haven't heard him yeah I
mean to be cool Wow but you know I'm
saying they're like I like to admit
stuff because my life is [ __ ] busy
and you're like I gotta get to Joshua
Tree and how many times you say like
it's the same thing of like when I tell
people you haven't been these cemani are
yet mine you got to go to you semi and
they go I'm gonna get there and it's
like in California it's not in like
Egypt no and it is one of the greatest
places on earth yeah well I had Joshua
tree the record so I had been there any
time not taking mushrooms many times I
didn't need the tree to do it so we were
out there and I and I realized and I'm
jumping ahead because you said you came
out to play open for the gun club and
then that gets you to move out here do
you land in the desert
back then or do you land in Hollywood
proper Hollywood Hollywood and get out
there at what age I was just turned 21
when we came out to open for the gun
club what are you still living in
Memphis until then oh yeah yeah oh you
didn't leave Memphis you graduated high
school there and everything oh yeah oh I
got you yeah and the band the modifiers
we we would go we would do a few shows
out of town not many mostly New Orleans
right and also at one point Alex Chilton
from big star and his own solo stuff he
he was the bass player in our band no
[ __ ] so he was a good friend he taught
me how to play the open tuning that I
played after big star oh yeah Wow he
joints your guys's band after big stuff
yeah he just well he he played a few
shows right yes he was coming I got
Scott tunas in my bad from Zappa yeah I
mean he broke the band you know Alex
just liked us he was kind of a mentor to
us he thought we were trippy liked our
scene was he living in Memphis uh yeah
he had just moved back from New York and
he was playing with a band called
Panther burn right he was playing with
us and then he moved to New Orleans and
we started playing down there he he
would host us when we would go there and
one night he showed me open G tuning the
Keith Richards tuning oh yeah we use in
Eagles of Death Metal so that was in
probably 1981
81 maybe and what was the sound of your
band what was the sound yeah we're we're
cow Punk so we did punk rock we did
country music we did a kind of amalgam
of both of those which cuz later you
play with text and the horse heads just
Cal Punk - that's how we we played a
bunch of shows with them and right when
you were around during the era were
Linda Perry starts working with her
bones no I wasn't oh yeah cuz I she
really was way into text and the horse
heads I wasn't the text moved to San
Fran after that she lived up there for a
short time and then she moved to Austin
where she still lives because I remember
she was like playing lots of gigs on
hates
eating stuff like the i-beam and hey a
night break and [ __ ] yeah we played a
night break of yeah did you play sushi
Sunday yep how great with us day and
night break was awesome that was a
[ __ ] legit Club oh man I said I saw
Primus there of new years of like 89 or
90 something like that badass back then
it was awesome because that plays
supported a whole like 200 people yeah
yeah they tore it down man well no it's
still there I mean now I mean uh-oh the
place down right like the actual room
still there it's weird it's just like a
bar now you're like oh I walk by and
then the bowling alleys gone it's amoeba
but that used to be rockin ball yeah the
rock and Bowl yeah [ __ ] yeah me both
killer though it's no meat it's great
too oh hell yeah so you go out to LA and
then you play the gig and you go [ __ ]
up we're moving out here the whole band
move out here or just yeah well for that
I the first time was 82 we drove out it
was it was August of 82 we opened for
the gun club on my mom's birthday Wow
and we all took acid Wow
and it was our craziest most hateful
show and my mom didn't really drink or
tell me that she was coming to the show
she was coming to the show in Hollywood
no in LA oh yeah I'm sorry in a Memphis
oh man her birthday yeah yeah and it was
our worst gig ever
you're all on us we're on acid and it
turned into like a hate fest with the
audience and just badass yeah and and
Jeffrey lead loved the show he thought
it was [ __ ] hilarious and then I saw
my mom after the show trip and I wasn't
expecting it and she'd gotten a buzz
that night she never did and she's like
you guys were so good oh wow so that was
cool she didn't disown me yeah I
probably could have yeah and so we
anyway we went to LA we played that show
and we just kind of hung for a week or
so just soaking it up figuring it out
but it was at 82 that's 82 how dirty is
Hollywood then Meryl that it was awesome
yeah I loved it man oh my god it was
like yeah it really was like [ __ ]
like there was a inner
gee they're oh that would heat you and
you could just float down the street
like wow man this is rock and roll it
truly was rock and roll more than any
place in the world at that the first
night we got into town was the night
before we played with the gun club and
we pulled up in front of the place that
we were gonna play called the Cafe de
grand yeah just to have all sorts of
punk bands and our friends who were
roadies in Black Flag they had a band
called [ __ ] heist yeah and we went to see
them and we went downstairs we were
drinking we met five people that I'm
still very very good friends with my
very first night and our singer
disappears and we're super drunk we met
all these girls that loved our whole
scene because we were these you know
young kids from Memphis that were gonna
be playing and here's how punked you got
that rockabilly look oh yeah I mean well
I had long hair at the time right I was
still a long hair you know kind of like
an X look like X was kind of you know
tight jeans and cowboy shirts yeah I had
snakeskin boots I was wearing leather
pants back then yeah kind of going for
it and uh so we couldn't find her singer
and Tex who was working at the club as a
waitress said I saw him I saw him leave
with this questionable lady she walked
out to that we she walked us out to the
alley and sure enough he gone out with
some girl and gotten mugged whoa so he
was laid out in the alley all our money
was gone he was holding all of her money
oh my god so she wheeled him out like
hey man you wanna you want to make out
herself
yeah robbed oh yeah alley and so Tex and
me and my buddy Bob took her back took
him back inside and then pleasant gaming
and iris Barry who I ended up playing
with all three of those girls I ended up
playing in bands with and our friend
Laura Bennett who I ended up being
friends with nursed him back to health
and then pleasant invited us back to her
and irises house called disgrace land it
deserves a payment like it's where you
know like a
the bangles used to hang out the go-go's
everybody everybody all seen yeah they
would all go back to this house and have
these crazy parties so we ended up
staying with her for a few days it's
funny because those three girls they
ended up playing with in several bands
over the years still great friends with
all of them but so we didn't have it
really together to stay that time so I
went back home we played a couple more
shows with Black Flag and Circle Jerks
and then came back Rawlins in the Black
Flag oh yeah yeah Wow like the first
time I didn't play I didn't open for
Black Flag because I was a part-time
member of the band while we were at home
right
and for the time member yeah then the
second time rotated in oh yeah yeah we
had a couple of different guitar players
that they would use
I had another band so we kind of right
so we got invited back out by Keith
Morris and a couple of people said yeah
if you guys come back out we'll get some
gigs circle chair gigs we came out we
made it we we ended up lasting about
three or four months and eighty-three
where were you living we were kind of
living all over we met a cool couple in
Venice and uh they had a daughter Laura
Norton who is now married to Chuck do
Kowski that oh yeah from Chuck Chuck was
supposed to do this podcast for a couple
years he's the cool who kept saying is
gonna do it and just never worked out
but they still live in Venice oh yeah oh
yeah they they live in the house that we
stay dies it's on you know it's right
they're still there and we had a van and
we would park the van there and we would
cook for the family and take the kids to
school and they'd let us park our van
there so we ended up staying there for a
few months and what was the Gold up but
maybe get a record deal good shot or
just played music or just moved to LA I
think it was more just moving to LA we
definitely didn't have anything about
record deal seems right Bobby too
so yeah we would just we were just
trying to hang out in LA we loved it I
mean you know Sun and surf [ __ ] yeah rod
Memphis yeah man it was great
so then we ended up moving up north at
the time you could live on Leo Carrillo
Beach in a couple of the parks for $3.00
a days we had a camper and a van and we
would just live on the beach for three
you know a dollar each a day the whole
band yeah no bands would do that anymore
oh no you know what I mean like we're
living in a [ __ ] van on a beach you
know people would be like wait a minute
does it got Wi-Fi Oh peanuts we got
really good man we would we would work a
little construction for friends and then
we drive out there we'd make dinner by
the beach go swimming play guitars all
night and do it all over so after three
or four months we were we had a ton more
songs and you know so we lived like that
and then we ended up kind of you know
nothing was really happening with us we
actually when we first came out we had
derf scratch from fear playing bass and
John Densmore from The Doors playing
drums are you kidding me yeah John
Densmore with you yeah Wow yeah actually
our first gig out here we didn't have a
drummer so bill Bateman from the
blasters just sat in with us Wow and
sounded I mean he knew the songs better
than our regular drummer
that's insane John Densmore though man I
mean yeah yeah he came back and played a
couple of shows with us in Memphis you
know that was that was a really big deal
for us to go back home yeah and and play
with John Densmore what was that guy
like cuz you know he to me really felt
like he had kept the credibility of like
[ __ ] you guys man Jim would not be into
this oh [ __ ] no you know he was awesome
man he was he would let us rehearse at
his house and he was super cool he said
you know he's a pretty interesting dude
he was a drummer and the doors you can
only imagine I'm behind but crazy and
what were they you know what was he 20
21 yeah and they split it all four ways
so he got tons of money I wish everybody
did that
you know just read the van Halen book
and they split it five ways fifth to the
manager oh really and I really think
that and we we get sidetracked on this
but it's always a big [ __ ] deal is
when you have chemistry it doesn't
matter if the guy didn't write or
anything if you all like we're talking
about slept in this van on at the beach
and starve together and and [ __ ]
battled shitty promoters and bad sound
and rehearsed and and [ __ ] food and and
lost your girls and everything that is a
commitment that's that at any company
like right now a start-up you would be
an owner absolutely maybe an owner my
band earthlings splits everything evenly
Mojave Lord splits everything evenly my
solo album I split it I'm even though I
wrote all the songs I split publishing
with everybody that played on it because
I feel like if they wouldn't have played
on it I mean still nothing has happened
anyway so it doesn't really matter right
but if anything did it would be because
those people played on it yeah I believe
that too because you know when you're
playing in bands and you get the right
guys you're like [ __ ] I don't want to
lose these guys you know I need to make
yeah and you're all sacrificing the same
amount of time and effort you know
absolutely so you guys are out now they
you're giving it a run yeah then it kind
of fell apart and you know just kind of
ran its course
and Tex Akala her BAM broke up so we
started playing together and our friend
Larry Mullins played drums now he went
on to play with Iggy for 20 years played
with the Stooges residents a lot of the
guys from Nick Cave and the Bad Seeds
Nick he's still an amazing drummer and
musician so he still produces and he's
around he moved to Sweden now so or
Norway actually yeah but anyway yeah we
had there was the scene here was amazing
man it was a real family wasn't like it
I mean I don't really know because I
don't
live here anymore so I don't go out all
the time right but back then you were
all family like you played with the same
bands at least once a month if not two
or three times a month the bills would
just go around and it wasn't competition
it was really fun to all get together
and do do it together you know is really
you look forward to hanging out with
your friends and putting on really great
rock shows right and where are you
playing at the time are you doing like
like Raji Raji Raji z-- we're doing a
club lingerie project how great was that
one of the best was it machine that was
machine yeah what was the place called
it was a asko's cave right here I
remember that place we'd played The
Scream a bunch scream that was the
scream before when it was like power
tools before it turned into scream I
remember going in there in 82 I think it
was 82 and it was like a scene from The
Hunger or something you know as goth
yeah and it was so dark and [ __ ] up
and it was great man it was so cool it's
so great man yeah but about censor Club
were you doing that pre Viper yeah we
would do central occasionally where else
I mean exposure 54 is that later that's
yeah we used to play this one place
called Ground Zero and it it was a you
would start the shows at 3 in the
morning
whoa it was an after-hours show you went
down this really long hall like super
long it kind of was like the maze to get
in but when you got in they were selling
electric kool-aid like acid spiked
kool-aid Wow
you buy cocaine any drugs that you I
mean it was a joy oh yeah I mean it was
fully illegal but it was called ground
zero and we played there tons and that
was always crazy because what was that
downtown or something no it was kind of
near we used to play the anti Club I
don't know that's like on Melrose by the
freeway and then Ground Zero was just
past that Wow it was weird I I can't I
don't know
never heard of that that's badass you
buy your drugs at the door yeah one of
our first gigs was at the anti Club I
met flea and Mike watt that night and
they were both giant durf scratch fans
because they loved fear and they were
kids you know like yeah little kids yeah
we all were you know yeah all right
that's so rad man and then do you end up
just staying out here
yeah after at the end of 84 I ended up
moving here and just kind of like taking
on odd jobs you know mostly pizza
delivery because that's the freedom job
that you don't mind losing if you if you
did get a tour you would you know if you
couldn't get your gig back it's no big
deal just work at another one when you
come back absolutely and I helped open
three restaurants at the Country Store
and Laurel Canyon oh yeah yeah yeah
underneath underneath there the Italian
joint
yeah they it started as Canyon pizza
which the guys the guys that own the
stores super cool right really cool
Iranian dudes that are all really really
cool same guys still owned it
oh yeah yeah all I'm still there every
day yeah super cool I used to get a
sandwich in there every day
the sandwich was a killer man killer man
I would sit on the wood there I just
soaked in that Laurel Canyon you know oh
it's so my dream was to live in Laurel
Canyon when I first moved here and then
I was like oh this traffic's horrible
Beachwood Canyon for me yeah I lived at
three houses in Laurel Canyon I loved it
up there yeah I do too
Betty's lived in that mansion that Ruben
bought were sugar sex Magik the team ins
oh yeah the brothers yeah oh I oh dude
on coke in there man they were they were
the same man is a man in the apes for a
while and then they were with a an LSD
life second out that's Alex Caine and
those guys Alex Kane remember those are
Stanley was the singer I'm a tank I'm a
tank
they're crazy some [ __ ] cheat a stole
my money yeah I just had Alex on the
show really and the Stanley guy lives
out in Malibu or whatever his riches
[ __ ] and he's just normal now are you
sure he was always rich that was just a
thing you know his thing was just act
crazy
oh yeah well he took it as like
theatrical like you know like a kiss or
Alice Cooper I kind of figured that I
heard stuff like that but he was always
crazy whenever he some but they were a
great band they were great dude they
were great we played with them a lot at
the lingerie oh yeah but you have the
same man and the Apes guys you know I
went up there I used to you know I'd see
those guys all the time but I heard
delivered a pizza to that house yeah
somebody was recording up there and I
saw a ghost up there Wow the only time
I've ever seen it ghost you saw guys
what I saw statue move around even
freaked me out what really wasn't stoned
or anything Wow but at that Rubin
mansion yeah man I always say that you
know people say hey you know my
apartments haunted in Hollywood I go I'm
sure they all are because the amount of
suicides in this town every apartments
had a suicide in it people here hoping
to make it boom I mean every apartment
it's made before the 80s people died in
that for anybody ever died in really a
mini you know but that mansion was it
was pretty uh it had a lot of history
the lady that owned it I think Stevie
Wonder had a birthday party there in the
70s and an Allen and Howard that lived
in the main one and then Erik lived in
the weird side house yeah
but they would scour that thing in the
Attic and stuff and they found Manson's
actual acoustic guitar in there yeah
and boxes and boxes of his records and
were you yeah and and Alan has Manson's
guitar and he did an episode here on my
podcast and talks all about it Alan team
and if anybody wants to hear it but
those days in that mansion were
unbelievable and that is
the Hollywood that I talk about over and
over and over
oh you got Jane's addiction's about to
hit you got GN R's about to hit the
strip is booming but you also have all
that other stuff going on you know all
the punk and stuff you know Chili
Peppers and all that I remember my buddy
Dean nail way from xxx record was he you
gotta go see my my band I'm putting out
there called Jane's Addiction they're
playing at Raji's and it was me and four
other people Wow and they were you know
it wasn't quite my thing at the time is
a little too disjointed right but I saw
them literally two months later at
scream yeah two thousand people packed
going crazy I've never seen I've never
seen an ascension of any band that fast
in my life it just like you know Raji's
was their first gig so maybe like two
three months later they'd played they
had played the rock scene recorded that
yeah oh yeah that album yeah and so but
I'd never seen that happen before you
know it's you know most people struggle
for years and years and nothing happens
and they were just they just got tight
and exploded and we you know opened for
them at the scream on Highland one time
too
a long time ago what a band I mean you
know though the best rhythm sections
going man oh God that guy's so great man
on drums you know and and Eric Avery you
know it's funny my buddy did a record
with Erica Avery he was produced at Ross
Robinson and he told me goes Oh Eric
Avery's the sound of that band oh yeah
because she's a great guy too
he was the guy right nose grooves and
stuff I boo do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do do-do you
know and all that stuff it's like and
that was a you know and properly
promoted as our Zeppelin for me because
I'm 51 and I didn't get to see Zeppelin
but they were correctly that that like
oh this is going to be the next Zeppelin
well that's what I mean like I when I
saw him at scream I went there not
really expecting many people to be there
or them to be and they were explosive
they somehow they just click super fast
yeah is a
it's weird when you think about when
some sudden lightning strikes even if
you talk about guns and roses
they didn't think yeah them at little
Club yeah but they didn't hit right away
like like James you know like it wasn't
like seven people in two thousand but
when you see bands you go oh well these
guys yeah they're gonna do it you know I
remember seeing Guns and Roses when I
see him maybe it like gazzarri's or
something yeah you know and they were
great then but they had a pretty fast
ascension to man they kind of right you
know they but they were hitting it hard
you know yeah I felt like back then that
if you didn't get a deal in about a year
and a half it was done that seemed about
right well you know what I'm saying
because you would see these bands they
were they were guys in other bands they
would get a band together like Gian or
whatever and all sudden it would just
take off and you go oh that's it and
then other bands would be just going
forever nothing you know it's funny I
was at a dinner party when we were
living in Venice and Rosanna Norton who
is Laura Norton's mom knew all these
famous people so she would always invite
famous people over and I can't think of
the guy's name right now he's a super
famous photographer he did a he did the
UFO phenomenon yeah what's the guy's
name I can't remember but I remember he
was like if you haven't made in LA nine
nine months you need to get the hell out
of here you're never gonna make it we
were there for about eight and a half
months at all ready to go yeah I'm still
haven't made it and I'm not still not
ready to go well there's a point where
who's looking you know there's I always
describe this to people of like what are
your what are your definitions of making
it to me it's doing art at 56 years old
like yourself that is 100% making it
other people they put a monetary thing
on it or whatever but I've been on stage
my entire life this would be like 35
years this year of being on stage from
music to comedy I've 100% made it yes
and I've totally made it that
I mean yeah I'm 56 and still playing
rock and roll which is pretty unheard of
unless you're ac/dc or the stones and
I'm playing in the most fun bands ever I
get to play with Eagles of Death Metal
Earthlings Mojave Lords masters of
reality you know I'm the luckiest dude
in the world time with Queens oh hell
yeah I played you know started Queens
with Josh yeah started Queens with Josh
let's talk about that because how do you
land from Hollywood and say I'm getting
the [ __ ] out and go to the desert
because I remember once caius hits I
start hearing about the desert scene the
generator parties and everything and and
I'm obsessed with caius at the time I'm
like this is the greatest band ever you
know and then when I go to see him I'm
like you know this pre videos oh yeah
those are the guys that Josh guy he's
got a buddy playing football or
something he's got that ovation guitar
he's and those weird and pegs about him
was so original but how do you bounce
out of Hollywood what what calls it a
day and you get out to the desert well I
ended up recording a record with
Pleasant and iris it goes back to the
girls I met the first night in LA and we
had a band called the Ringling sisters
and we got it Lou Lou Adler decided to
produce our record he yeah rock in the
Hall of Fame now oh yeah like Felice I
mean Mamas and the Papas Rock'em Horror
Picture Show I mean yeah his genius do
Cheech and Chong Cheech and Chong genius
guy yeah super cool too
we did a record with him 4:00 a.m. this
is good big time it's five girls doing
poetry Mamas and the Papas harmony
I mean it's ready to blow up everybody
working at a.m. that was pushing our
album got fired in the same day clean
house that was the end of that and at
the time everything was business music
business it got from fun to business and
I and I what you're looking at we're
looking at 92 oh that's where like the
Grothe the the hair
drops off yep people clean houses yeah
and we're getting ready here comes the
grunge Mach 2 perhaps absolutely
so in Hollywood becomes tumbleweeds yeah
so everybody's out of there so I was
playing with another with some other
friends called continental drifters and
yet another band I was an auxilary
member we had all changed up whoever
because they had a residency at Raji's
for years and so I would play quite
often with them they got a gig at Jazz
Fest in New Orleans now I wasn't invited
to play but I told him I had a bunch of
weed and mushrooms and could I ride in
the RV and they're like oh yeah yeah you
know where you gonna stay in you know
I'll figure it out yeah the drummer
Carlo new CEO said just stay with me and
my family it's cool so we drive across
country we get to their managers house I
knock on the door he opens the door we
become best friends instantly and I end
up staying there and hanging with him
and idly you know we they play the show
we go back home and then my friend Larry
is malaria Mullins is going to New
Orleans to record with Iggy Pop right so
I'm like hey can I ride with you because
they were doing it at Daniel Lanois
studio Kings well I'm believable and I
was like I'll just go if you if it's
cool I'll ride with you back and forth
and he's like yeah so we stayed at the
Kings Way for a few days before the band
got there 101 of the motifs as a duo is
the Teatro another amazing play is what
it says silver like blows my mind I've
never been there but I heard I heard
it's insane it's actually insane I got
the weirdest lanois story I'm at the
side land in LA Silver Lake and I'm
living behind Spaceland and I'm at the
7-eleven every day and then I keep
seeing this guy on this [ __ ]
motorcycle and he goes and I pull up on
my bike and he starts talking to me you
know and and he goes yeah I ride you
ride
I write every day because where do you
got I got a few Harley's I got a v-rod I
got a road King so yeah I got this
Beemer and I got the hell over right
around the corner stop by and I'm in his
house and I'm [ __ ] looking around I
go this is [ __ ] Daniel Lanois
I can't even [ __ ] believe it I'm
calling my buddies cuz I I am such a
giant u2 guy oh yeah you know and at the
time I was an his solo album oh god that
one that solo record is so [ __ ] good
the one with him on the cover that the
blue covered one that records for no but
he shown me stuff like yeah here's the
this is uh this is Bono's Gretsch
Cadillac green Gretch Tennessee here
this is the guitar Emmylou Harris played
the j-200 on this record and it's just
[ __ ] giant house with stained glass
and a fake kind of like river pool I'll
make pool and stuff and we became
friends you know and I'd see him all the
time at my buddy's leather shop Lords he
got hit on his bike man and that was bad
but anyway side track but it's funny
when you land in LA and you're 2 feet
from one of the greatest of all time
yeah but you stay at Manoir studio for
the first two days before their band got
there and then I went and stayed with my
buddy who I met before the night before
I got there someone had broken in and he
had to shoot the guy shoot the guy yeah
he shot blue the guy's hand off what
blue the guy's hand off and I had to
stay in that room
still blood and everything some guy
broke it he just shoots him he shot him
who shot him my buddy Jimmy Ford who I
still play with to this day in a band
called the gnarl times I play with him
and his wife that's right he's the
raddest dude you will ever meet Jimmy
Ford man Wow the guy go running
oh yeah the guy ran he got caught he'd
killed people and he had killed people
he's in jail forever now
so I had to stay there anyway at the end
of this trip in New Orleans yeah Jimmy's
like I want to take you by this bar this
is where like he he marches and the the
Mardi Gras parades and so it's like this
is where our marching crew meets in the
morning before Mardi Gras morning I want
to show you and we walk in the only two
people at the bar are both of his aunts
they're sitting at the at the bar
drinking yeah he introduces me to the
owner and the in the aunts we have a
couple of drinks we leave I fly home he
calls me two days later and says you
know that bar took you to I'm like yeah
I guess they're looking for somebody to
take over the restaurant I was like all
right I'll let you know and he goes no
it's got to be you and I was like well
I've got bands you know I can I don't
have any money and goes dude this place
for it for the the the restaurant the
the venue and two floors above it with
six bedrooms is a thousand bucks a month
including utilities oh my gosh I was
like I'll see you tomorrow
oh my god yeah and I immediately came
back I finished recording I was
recording at a place called Dominion way
with Fred Drake who I started the studio
with so anyway we finished this this
recording and I told everybody I was
playing with I'm moving I'm starting a
restaurant city you know I'm not
changing directions so I moved to New
Orleans I opened this restaurant in 92
in 92 this is probably like in August or
so of 92 in October and November I get a
call from Fred Drake who I'd worked on
records with at this place yeah he tells
me our friend Dean Chamberlain that
owned the studio is selling all his gear
and I'm like that's great guys I think
you'd be a great partner for this yeah
but I just opened this restaurant you
know and I don't have a lot of money
because it's 6,000 bucks for all his
gear all his recording gear yeah that's
Mike's everything we can pay him $100
down in 50 bucks a month he doesn't care
he just wants to get out of the business
I sent him
three thousand dollars from my half the
next day and we had a studio and where
do you get in that you get well what
kind of board and we had a sound craft
series 600 board right uh some my crazy
[ __ ] yep we got a fostex 16 track half
inch oh wow we got you know whatever
punk rock stuff yeah not a lot but you
know a few mics all the cable everything
to record right but I'm in New Orleans
yeah so he sets it up
where is he set it up back at the
rancher at the ranch so he know he has
the buildings already instead he's
already living out there and he sets it
up out there and I had no I was like you
know maybe in a year or something I'll
be able to go out there and record right
with him because he's such a great guy
so a few months later fire at the
restaurant oh not horrible but enough to
just to shut it down shut it down and
shut down where we were living the
people that own the building weren't
insured so there goes my business that I
paid 6 months in advance and so I try to
live there for a couple of months
without electricity
yes squats down oh yeah we had cold
water and that was it and then I get a
call from hutch and he says because you
know our buddies caius are going to
Europe and they're looking for a guitar
tech I mean you want to just get it
because I was telling like I don't know
what the hell I'm gonna do like I'm
stuck here you know I'm looking for
something because doesn't pay a lot and
I've never been to Europe and it was
like yeah Alice yeah yeah Europe let's
do is go to Europe with caius I mean you
know I've hi they were they were oh you
know my best friend you know so we went
to Europe had a blast I come back from
Europe who decides they want to record
at Rancho Daniel Lanois what how does he
know about it Trina's shoemaker who
didn't eared rated-r right who learned
how to engineer from Fred Drake Wow
so she had told Dan and
and uh you know his crew about this
place in the desert and he sent his guy
mark Howard out to look at it mark came
in this is cool I think he'll go for it
here's what's gonna happen we're gonna
bring his Neve and his Stu Teran all his
gear we're gonna leave it here for six
months to a year and he'll probably
record here he's in the middle of doing
you know probably whoever will II know
right oh yeah wait but yeah he was like
he'll probably do three weeks over the
year but you can we won't pay you but
you can use the gear music so he's gonna
sub it out cuz he closes down Teatro
know know that he was in Mexico so he
could he thought he was cursed by a
witch in New Orleans at the time he'd
bought a military mess tent uh-huh
erected it on the beach in Mexico and
set up all his gear on the beach are you
kidding me I'm not kidding and he had a
studio in a tank on the back one of
those big army team s10 yeah so when
when they when they brought everything
out we unrolled the tent and [ __ ]
scorpions were crawling scorpions but
they brought all the gear in they set it
up they they did everything that we
needed and he came a couple of times but
once he came while I was there and he
had Daryl Johnson playing bass and Brian
Blade playing drums the two baddest I
mean Brian blades probably one of the
best drummers in the world right and
they jammed and me and Fred were there
fred was on an IV cuz he was really sick
at the time he's just walking around the
house with an IV oh my god Lanois really
loved Fred and he got so anyway after he
left we did
caius and wool they did us which guy's
record does a split single with with
wool Oh
I can't remember what maybe it was I
can't remember the name now you know our
somewhere along the way you you get some
engineering skills are you just
producing or what are you doing
strangely enough I took engineering in
high school so I want a little bit about
it and you know I knew how to get around
I suck at Pro Tools but I'm good at that
analog and analogue I'm great so anyway
we did some Caius and and wool and then
Victoria Williams record so that people
started asking us about the studio and
then Caius broke up and Josh and I were
friends and he went to business school
for a while and then he decided he
wanted to put together a band and he
came back and he started doing it with
Fred like he just like hey Fred I want
to jam so he went up and actually Fred
and him jammed on the first queen stuff
and then he and I tried to put together
Josh and I tried to put together a
couple of like we tried it with Brant
Bjork and a couple of different people
and we write it with Adam maples drummer
for Earthlings and finally he just
decided he went up back to he went back
to Seattle
and put together Mike Johnson and Matt
Cameron and they started doing shows up
there recorded some stuff and then the
early Queen stuff yeah Matt Cameron
played in early Queens yeah holy [ __ ] is
for a couple of shows I think wow I
never knew that ever yeah and then he
came back and we put together some stuff
and he's cuz we moved up there and he
was playing with Lanigan right he was
playing with screamin tree right
screaming trees yeah so yeah just kind
of you know happened because we were
friends and then that stuff didn't work
up there so he came back and we really
started we did a bunch of demos of the
songs and then finally he started the
record at Rancho with Alfredo and him
just doing most of the stuff they were
gonna have me play a little bit here and
there and Mike Johnson was playing bass
and for some reason that didn't work out
so they squashed that for a second then
he did it at goss's studio Goss had a
studio in the low desert
monkey studio and that's where he ended
up doing the record him and Alfredo and
I played a little bit on it at hutch
played a little bit on it Goss played a
little bit
and then after that album came out I
started touring with him so I played
with with Queens from 97 through 2003
dough alfredo and then and then at one
point it turned into me Nick and Josh
and Jean Troutman and then after that I
started getting busy with Earthlings you
know I was that was my band
yeah with with Queens it was I was just
playing Josh's song so I kind of split
off I really you know started doing my
own stuff well that Earthlings record
the 98 one with the alien on the cover
yeah the weird looking thing it's so
funny I didn't even know it was your
band so I got guys wearing an Earthling
shirt [ __ ] [ __ ] I love our thorns man
those guys are great you know that's my
bad I didn't have a [ __ ] it was one
of those things where someone turned me
on to it a long time ago and I never
even looked who was in the band I would
just play that thing all the time
oh yeah Pete's tall singing I'm a Bulls
on drums
[ __ ] great yeah Dave Grohl plays
drums on one of our songs
Pete Pete brought Dave out there right
after everything happened with Kurt
needs he was like you need to come out
to the desert and meet my friends out
there so he came out and we spent like a
whole day just jamming and we ended up
getting a song out of it
Wow well and so you obviously when you
leave New Orleans and you just moved to
Rancho and just never look back I moved
I actually moved to LA with a Pete stall
and the whole crew of people Lydia
Russell who was running man's ruin at
the time oh man dr. Josh was dating her
at the time and Pete and his sister were
living at the house and then one of the
houses next door came up for rent next
door to Rancho and hutch and I moved out
there how'd you meet hutch
I met hutch because he was married to
Pleasant gamin who I ended up that's who
I met the first night I was in LA I
ended up playing in the Ringling sisters
and a band called honk if you're horny
which is our triple x-rated country band
Wow and
when we were friends he started dating
her and then they ended up getting
married so man he's the best he's you
know I'm gonna have him on the show but
I really feel there should be a
documentary on huts you know that would
be a good one man he's got a long story
for sure he recently retired man right
from from the road yeah you know he and
his lady opened there got a place yeah
they got a venue called Lagrange yeah
and it's gonna be kind of like an Austin
City Limits place I'm gonna do comedy
out there oh you got - yeah we're gonna
we're gonna do maybe a comedy show out
there once a month bring some guys out
there dude that would be it's it's a
really awesome venue yeah I saw the
pictures it's great yeah you'll love it
let's talk a little bit of Rancho it
some of the records that have been done
in there some great stuff that sonic
highways stuff was that had to be cool
for you guys her on it that was awesome
you know Dave and I've been friends for
a long time and he hit me up to the I
was really surprised because in LA think
of all the amazing studios you could
have gone to totally [ __ ] Ocean Way
my god yeah Sound City Valentine my
[ __ ] mind still but yeah yeah so you
can imagine my surprise when you decided
to take it out there and it was pretty
it was a really great experience I mean
Dave's a great guy and he also since
he's so successful not only can he hire
the best of the best he can hire the
coolest of the best why the best so
everybody that worked for him is super
super cool and the best so having all
those guy I mean a lot of his we've
toured with you know we've done a bunch
of shows with Foo Fighters and stuff so
all their crew were all great friends
and you know hutch toured with you know
we're all the whole thing is like a big
family so I so yeah that was it was a
giant undertaking it was a lot more than
I thought
I know I thought they would just use my
gear and they came in semis almost you
know giant moving trucks full of
you know tape machines and stuff from
his studio holes I didn't realize they
were taking two tape machines to every I
don't know if they did it for every
place for 606 they would just bring it
with him on yeah
wow that was a [ __ ] great series oh
man amazing it really was great and I
think it's underrated I think it it
really opened up a lot you know I could
taught me a lot about certain cities you
know me too men me too
like that whole DC thing man I mean I'm
51 and you you know I realized that you
can get turned on to stuff that happened
you know years ago from a scene that you
had no idea about absolutely that's it
like you know Here I am all digging into
the desert scene like you don't know
about the desert scene like what you
don't know about DC and then somebody
else like you don't know about you know
whatever you know whatever scenes yeah I
really love that series I thought he did
an excellent job of showing people what
the roots of those cities really was all
about I'm looking forward to another one
they were talking about trying to do
like Europe or you know like I think
that would be really interesting Berlin
London and all these great places I was
trying to get with Dave Grohl I have no
connection I'm trying to get with him
yeah I'm trying to you know what I mean
he's kind of sexy but he's busy as [ __ ]
but I really wanted to pitch the same
kind of vibe but go to cities where calm
lots of comics came from being Boston
you know myrrh and and CK that's a great
night yeah and they go to go to like
Houston and that that Kennison and Bill
Hicks era
go to San Francisco and cover the those
guys there and these errors of comedy
and why these guys are funny as [ __ ]
from this era and then you know at the
end instead of doing a song at them I do
a set in the town that these famous guys
were from you know I love that idea I
know I was like it's a now it's going to
do it just on a motorcycle right
you know but I don't know how to get
ahold of them you know but I think it's
a it's a it's like sonic highways but
you know funny highways it's another
version of it but done great the sonic
haha way yeah sonic hollows the reason
that works so good is how it looked and
the flow of it it didn't feel cheesy
like a behind the music or whatever no
no no yeah it felt great man you you now
you're putting in eagles of death metal
of course and that documentary was
[ __ ] crazy heavy yeah I haven't
watched that yet you haven't watched it
yet saw like a rough cut a long time ago
and you don't want to watch it because
it did I mean I don't even I don't
really know yeah I don't like watching a
lot of stuff with me in it so right yeah
that was a pretty rough you know pretty
rough time so yeah maybe watching it
isn't that yeah that's a great
documentary though and also so heavy
yeah Colin's awesome man yes he's a
great guy and a great friend and he you
know the fact that he wanted to do that
when we went back to do the the live
show after that was definitely the
hardest show I've ever played and it
wasn't my best show only because the it
was so emotional I mean a lot of the
people that were at bodycon were in the
same they made a concerted effort to be
in the same spots that they were at the
bottle on it was part of their way of
dealing with it yeah so look it was it
was you know good goose bumps he knows
yeah and so very emotional for us but
you would look out and people would be
like laughing and then they'd be crying
you know and then looking around I mean
that was you know yeah heavy yeah I
don't even I couldn't even you know
imagine you know I mean it's one of the
most famous thing you know growing up
when you hear about the like I still
think and it's not terrorists but I
still think back to that
whoo concert in Cincinnati oh yeah I
still I still think about that like god
damn these people are just there to have
rock and roll and feel good and they got
trampled do you know and it's like I
still think back of these tragic things
of when you're at a show to celebrate
art and and you're there and something
bad happens you know yeah it's yeah it's
yeah man it's [ __ ] crazy
did you was hard to play gigs after that
I mean I will say that you too I can
never thank them enough for getting us
to come back to Paris
yeah that soon after everything happened
because them being so cool and gracious
I mean they flew us over first-class
they eat I don't think I would have
wanted to play for a while
maybe ever who knows I mean I would
definitely was not in a hurry to play
any shows and I was actually in New York
with my girlfriend Brandi just you know
trying to clear my head of the whole
thing and Josh called and said you can't
tell anyone but you Tues invited you
guys to go back over and play with them
and immediately said yes because I knew
that was gonna be safe you know for sure
if ever if you're ever a gig that's
gonna be pretty safe and we got there
and they you know they embraced us so
well they were so cool and you know that
what bono said you know these guys were
robbed of their stage and we're gonna
give it back to him to finish their show
that was those guys are so cool and
after that [ __ ] you know it was it was
heavy that was a great show that the
crowd there you know you really felt the
crowd was with us because of everything
you know that we were back and after the
show they had it was the end of tour so
they through this one of the coolest
parties you know just those guys were
just hanging out drinking champagne you
know
a beautiful view of the Eiffel Tower in
the background tons of great food super
cool people and each one of those guys
made a point of talking to us and just
amazing you know Adam Adam Clayton gave
Matt his base that he played that like I
want you to have this base Wow
and you know they are asking me you know
which which guitar of the 50 would you
like to play tonight Malika how about
the famous Les Paul that all that cool
stuff so I got to play his Les Paul and
Wow they're like which amp would you
like to play we have these fender this
one fender is one that Neil Young gave
the edge I'm like I'll take that Neil
Young but they just if they wouldn't
have done that
I don't know how right quick to jump on
a live show I would have been and after
that we went back on tour and yeah for a
while I was definitely looking around
the yeah the venue's for sure yeah
looking around and making sure
everything was cool but our first show
was in I can't remember it was either
either in Norway or Sweden and it was
crazy I mean like we walked on stage and
we got a 10-minute standing ovation Wow
it was people you know we got the best
we got the best fans in the whole world
you really do man we do it's it's all
you know it's it's all people come in to
shake ass and have a great time yeah and
people are always just super nice to us
and go to have a good time and everybody
seemed to be super happy that we were
back and that made us you know but for a
while definitely I was I was looking
around the places it's interesting that
u2 was the band because before we
started the podcast we were talking
about just how magical Joshua Tree is
and
they had the monster record Joshua Tree
and when I'm out there and it's such a
part of your life it's it's weird that
it's almost like a full circle you to
Joshua Tree you living out there it's
this whole desert thing that always
seems to bring magic to the whole team
of you guys you know yeah it's
interesting when Fred moved out to
Rancho before we had the studio well on
my first trip to LA up for the gun club
show on the way there Bob Omar guitar
player was you know back in the days
when he had maps and cell phones yeah he
looks on the map he's like hey Joshua
Tree National Park man we're not in a
hurry let's cruise through there cuz you
can go get in there off the ten so so we
went through it and blown away just
blown away
you know it's 82 not many people living
out there you know we drove through and
it it was like from 82 through like 87
probably I didn't really even think
about it and then it popped in my mind
and I said I think I saw a commercial
with it and I was like oh yeah and I
looked on the map
two hours I'll just leave at 10 in the
morning and you know go out there for
the day and I started doing that a lot
right Steve AG's doing that yeah do that
you know I believe at 10 in the morning
get there by noon and then after I
learned the thing I would take mushrooms
as soon as I hit the 62 and by the time
I got in the park I'd be coming on to
them yeah go camp you know crawling
around yeah would you camp there oh yeah
yeah oh yeah all the time
yeah but then when Fred moved there I
used to go visit him you know and I
would go cruise around and stay at his
house which is now my house
yeah and yeah but all I always felt
magic in that house always yeah we
started recording we've only had a
couple of small instances of people
having a bit of trouble there but most
everyone opens up and writes a song or
has a great session you know it's right
it's a very special place Joshua Tree
Inn
particular I mean ostrich tree in
general but that house especially is
very very special now the owner died and
the the parents have or the kids have it
right his wife has it right and I just I
just talked to her yesterday
and you know I've rent this place a lot
of people think that I own it right they
you know it's special to them too you
tried to buy it from them right I tried
for 25 years and fine you know she she's
gonna wait until she passes and then
they said it they'll sell it to me no
problem right oh they'll sell it to you
she said that yesterday yeah so she
finally said she'll sell it to you yeah
how have you this is what question I
want to ask you because a buddy of mine
wants to get like an Airstream put it
out there and just kind of [ __ ] chill
and you know how have you seen that
desert change because when you're
thinking about the old days it's really
people that wanted to get away and hide
it's like a Bolinas in NorCal where
maybe some Vietnam vets
yeah well that are like you don't like
society the grind they disappear out in
the desert that's a desert vibe and for
years and years it's like you know air
quotes meth heads and and and hippies
and radicals out there you know but how
have you seen it change because now it's
big money out there right I mean did not
not LA big money right yeah I mean when
we first moved out there unlimited
supply of homesteader cabins back in the
50s if you built a certain size cabin
they would give you five acres if you
homesteaded it oh wow so at the time
there were thousands of these places you
know thousands everybody would get five
acres yeah for free are free Wow if you
homestead it right so a lot of these
places didn't have water a lot of them
did they'd have power and water but
they'd be and back then
20 to 40 grand you it you would you know
20 to 40 grand
five acres easily like all day long Wow
all day long yeah forever and then at
one point when everything got really
high those places were like 75 which
back then you were like hell no I ain't
paying 75 but a few people would
whatever yeah and then they went they
died back down to like you know back up
thing 55 right kind of in the middle
there and then it became hip like do you
think it's Coachella that made that
whole area hip bringing people out to it
like wow this is cool what do you think
it was I think me and hutch just open
our yaps way too many times how cheap
and awesome and then Coachella of course
yeah Palm Springs got hip and then all
the sudden other people are like hey I
like this and there's all that
incredible architecture out there you
know you got those metal homes you've
got all the ultra-modern Zand and you've
got great [ __ ] out there I'll say people
are like hey this is cool
oh yeah I mean that's why gossip doubt
there that's why I moved out there when
you know when Chris and Cynthia you know
when when she found Caius and talked
Chris and they're producing him and they
started going out there they found like
a movie star home for like I don't know
800 bucks a month or something or you
know a pool and you know I mean it was
amazing and they were paying you know so
I think a lot of what really did this is
three things not being able to get a
house for under $350,000 in LA right or
house shitty in the a shitty
neighborhood Airbnb and the the fact
that out there if you looked a little
bit for 75 grand you'd have a decent
house on five acres and then Airbnb hit
and then everybody was like well he'll
at least buy that pay it off and have
that and then what I want to move out a
la so I think that's you know yeah plus
it's beautiful you know it is a special
place out there it's pretty [ __ ] hot
in the summer oh my god man what's the
hot but not but it's not as hot as Palm
Springs is that right
it's ten degrees hotter
minimum all the time in Palm Springs
well I didn't I never knew that why is
that guys there's a altitude or the
altitude yeah oh yeah cuz you go up now
what what are we talking about for
property there now like a house like as
it got got crazy for compared to what it
used to be you know like there's a kind
of a crappy neighborhood that's right in
town and I looked at a house for 30
grand like four years ago
yeah size of an apartment with a tiny
yard but nonetheless 30 grand yeah and
those houses are 160 170 now Wow I mean
I'm sure there's a deal out there but it
ain't like it used to be forever you
know but still you know if you if you're
looking at three four probably four
hundred thousand now in LA yeah get
$160,000 house like yeah mmm you know
it's okay you gotta be self continue
gotta be like you work where you work
because yeah there ain't no jobs out
there now there ain't no jobs or
anything so you have to either have
money or you work at home and you can
live anywhere yeah I often was I was
thinking about this while I was out
there all you guys tour a lot so when
you fly you got to go all the way to LAX
Palm Springs to Palm Springs yeah Palm
Springs International you can are they
oh yeah always have been
I never [ __ ] knew that yeah do you fly
out of Palm Springs sometimes you know
the problem with Palm Springs is it's
not LA so it's you know a lot of
connects your connections sometimes
sometimes that works out to easier to
fly to LAX and just drive home right or
you know there's there's you know Orange
County or there's you know oh yeah
there's closer yeah big airports but
yeah it's kind of a pain in the ass yeah
yeah right you're getting ready to leave
on tour tomorrow you guys are going out
five weeks this will be out today
yeah with with again they got and
Russian Circles hoorah again Russian
Circles same it's kind of a pick up of
that tour from earlier this year yeah I
mean we've all been friends for a long
time and when I stood on released a EP
on Friday I know and it's killer
those guys are great man if I've been
smooth they shred
oh and Russian Circles I'd never met
them but I've been a fan of theirs for a
while they're super cool guys and their
stuff is huge and cinematic and it's
pretty awesome I saw you guys at the
Palladium yeah yeah oh one thing I
wanted to mention is I got a new radio
show playing playing metal for gimme
radio it's a new radio station Oh what
is it we're all gimme radio.com it's
free yeah my friend my friend Dean wrist
blur got me involved in and he plays
with the dictators amongst many other
babe where'd you find this at uh if you
just look up give me radio.com gi mm e
radio down what do you do a show weekly
or I do a show every week yeah and you
play metal on it yep
are you a big metal guy I like I like
hard rock I might my show is proto metal
so my stuff is 60 70 s 80s predominantly
I do I do I like I play Mastodon and you
know but uh you big merciful fate guy oh
hell yeah
God Yeah right yeah man but my stuff is
more you know like UFO yeah yeah yeah
Saxon like my show last week was more
the punk rock roots of metal oh yeah
like you played some flag yeah you know
yeah but yeah check that out if you
haven't checked it out yeah you would
love it man it small overrate station
really cool people involved to him all
over that there they were they're really
cool they did a lot of push for Brian's
- that's great that was cool really
before we go
karinna V you got the Gabriel I had him
on Echo Park guitars I found out
basically from all you guys playing I'm
and then I had him on and it's
incredible I went to his house in
Detroit I didn't agree when oh god that
house is great but you got the creative
Vee you've been playing it every since
oh yeah man that thing I've it took a
big digger in in Paris and he I brought
it back and he put a whole new neck on
it now and it's it's it's my favorite
guitar you know I
yeah that's my guitar I mean you are
known as the V guy you know I love it
man yeah what are your amps right now
I'm playing orange Oh our 50s and I just
got a I just got a I used my Z key quite
often and a guy Jim Taylor out of
Portland made me Al Anam a what Al Anam
that's a new it's a new amp and he let
me borrow one and I had to get one how
is it it sounds amazing so between the
Zinke the lanham and the the orange yeah
I've got the spectrum covered you got
the [ __ ] men you got the metal
command I've got the metal command yeah
so I hope everybody comes out to see
these shows man Russian sir like get
there early for Russian Circulo and then
we play in the middle and then Macedon
just takes it on home I can't wait man
you guys come in to LA at all again we
are doing San Diego I'll win that is
that's good you have to look at all I
get up you go Eagles of Death Metal tour
I'm gonna go I will yeah you need to
come down there for that I'm going to
that it's gonna be a good one well
thanks for doing the show dude you know
how much I love you I'm so glad
hopefully you'll have me back on and oh
and some other I would have you on twice
a year like a series
let's do great would that be on my gimme
radio show oh my give me radio show is
called ascendant oral architects the
body on your radio show any time and I
still want to come out me goss in you
and do a song at Rancho let's do it BOC
on bass yeah let's go GRC and I'm Joey C
and and Jean Troutman will do double
drums yeah and then let's let's just
I told Goss you guys we get in the room
and we record one song completely
organic from the ground up and just and
then we make it my my intro to a song
for every show I ever do on my podcast
let's do it yeah and also I want to do a
documentary on me
so I want I want to record the music at
Rancho for the documentary out there why
don't we shoot for December is that
looking good I'm in every man for real I
wanted I really want to do this hand we
shook hands everybody and we'll do it
and it'll be the end it'll be the song
for now on starting 2018 the Rancho song
for let there be talk it's gonna happen
it's happen thank you so much Instagram
is I took this picture I took this photo
I took this photo and Rancho de la Luna
is the Twitter and Bo C's GoFundMe page
please go there and donate is go fund
me.com Brian O'Connor yeah and do this
please and also I'll give you guys a
heads up when we start doing these
desert comedy shows the desert laugh
sessions all right the last and stay
tuned also for Hutch will be here he's
going to be doing this pretty soon so
thanks guys for tuning in and don't
forget to subscribe to this podcast
that's how we get it into the number one
there on iTunes see you guys candles lit
[Music]